I woke up this morning
trying not to panic because
I've bitten off
a hell of a lot to do but if I panic
I won't get done
so I just need to get through this day and
every other day one step at a time
the good news is that the days are flying by
and the bad news
is that the days are flying by
and there's just not enough hours within them
I started my day the way that I always do
by raiding my anti anxiety station
and doing some breath work
because I think that that's the only thing
that's keeping me slightly sane
made a coffee checked on the pool progress
snuggled my babies
and then it was time to get busy with my first chore of the day
and genuine question but how we keeping
lunch boxes fun and exciting year round?
I try to vary what I give them day to day
but I think I need some fresh inspiration
today we had ciabatta and plain white bread for my daughter
beetroot hummus lettuce from the garden and some roast chicken
and don't get me wrong I would love to get some more veggies in there
but this is all that they wanted
I gave them a side of fruit salad each
and then for the snacks I kinda got lazy and
gave them a side of pretzels
mini Oreos and a gummy watch
but I was running out of time at this point
I finished the lunches packed the bags
raced through the bathroom
did some skincare
forgot to turn my camera on
love that for me
and then into the car we went
once all the babies were dropped off
I raced through the shops
because I needed to get some tomato plants
to donate to the school
and then because I think the theme of
the day today must be racing
and forgetting to turn my camera on
I raced through the chores and only captured part of them
I did a bit of email admin
and then it was time to make some breakfast for my tradie
I toasted up a couple bagels
top that with avocado lettuce
bacon and some cheesy eggs
can't forget pepper and a dollop of hollandaise
then I took that outside
to where Mark had been working tirelessly
since first thing this morning
because we're not only racing the clock with this pool
but we're racing the weather as well
but you just can't leave an old pool empty for long
cause it can cause some really major issues
so as soon as we get a fine day
it's all hands on deck and by all hands
I mean just Mark and I’s because
nobody wants to help us
I picked the kids up from school
made everyone some afternoon tea
and my husband got a beer as part of his afternoon tea
and then it was time for olive and I to head out again
because she's got a piano lesson
and while I was waiting for her to have her lesson
I went to the florist and then the supermarket
you know really fkn riveting stuff
and then I got home and straight into cooking dinner
I've been really loving these Cassia at home curry sauces
they taste very authentic
and it made dinner so quick and easy
I sauteed up some chicken
onion capsicum
and then added the curry sauce
meanwhile I had my rice cooking before
frying up some poppadoms
it was quick and hearty and comforting
which was exactly what I needed after a long day
but can someone please tell me how we're plating up rice these days?
cause I still do it like it's 1989
then I hit the wall, had a shower
and was asleep by 8:30
it was bliss